The main point of what I just showed
you is that instead of looking at all
possible paths, by using recursion,
we can look at n squared t paths.
And remember, the reason we
can do this recursion is that,
that, that recursive form, formula
only looks back at the previous state.
We're taking advantage of
that Markovian property.
And with just the forward algorithm,
we can evaluate the probability
of seeing that entire observation
sequence, given the machine.
So for example, and I haven't yet
told you how to do this,
if we had trained up a bunch of HMMs,
and some new observation sequence comes
in, I could have told you which one was
most likely using just the recursive,
just the forward recursive algorithm.
Right?
It requires the As and the Bs,
but that's what it means
to have trained up the HMM.
So I want to tell you about
the rest of the problems, but
I'm just going to tell it you in words.
I'm not going to give you the math and
you can go look,
there are A bunch of tutorials on HMMs
out there if you want to do the math.
They're pretty straightforward,
all right?
So, the forward recursive
algorithm that I just showed you,
can compute the likelihood of
being in state i at time t.
And having seen all
the observations up to time t,
given that you have the HMM lambda.
You can similarly define
a backward algorithm.
All right,
just sort of starts from the back,
goes backwards instead of the front.
And it's a recursive algorithm
that computes the likelihood
of being in state time t and seeing
the remainder of the observations.
Again, given the, the HMM.